[Música]
hola que tal espero que estén teniendo
un excelente día
gustaría comenzar con una pequeña
pregunta para ustedes qué es un viaje
para mí un viaje es una aventura llena
de experiencias y momentos de
aprendizaje
una aventura que está fuertemente
relacionada con momentos de convivencia
con otras personas existen muchos tipos
de viajes cada uno con un propósito
distinto
estos viajes te llevan a conocerte mejor
a ti y a ver la vida desde una
perspectiva diferente
pero lo más importante de un viaje es su
propósito ya que es lo que te ayuda a
generar grandes recuerdos sobre él y un
viaje sin propósito no genera grandes
recuerdos
para mí ha habido tres viajes que más me
han impactado que son los de convivencia
los de aprendizaje y los de conexión con
la naturaleza
empezando con el primero me gustaría
contarles una pequeña historia mi
familia y yo normalmente vamos todos los
veranos a un pueblo en españa llamados
eje de sajambre
en este pueblo hacemos rutas de
senderismo donde generamos momentos de
diversión conexión al con la naturaleza
y convivencia una de las ideas más
importantes ha sido cuando hace cinco
años mi papá y yo regresamos de una ruta
al pueblo nos deja ahí a medio camino
nos encontramos con un familiar muy
querido llamado herminio
herminio tenía 82 años de edad y era un
muy buen amigo de mi abuelo
con el platicamos sobre la ruta de
senderismo la ganadería en las montañas
las fiestas patronales y sobre mi abuelo
a quien él conocía desde que eran muy
pequeños
esto podría parecer una situación normal
nada del otro mundo pero lo más
impactante fue que pocos meses después
de este encuentro el niño falleció
esa fue la última vez que lo vi
esto me puso a pensar como la vida se va
en un instante y hay que aprovechar cada
día como si fuese el último
también como no conozco mucho a mis
abuelos
como ellos al igual que herminio deben
de tener un sinfín de historias que
contar así que aquí decidí empezar un
nuevo proyecto personal aprovechar estos
viajes de convivencia para realizar una
serie de entrevistas a mis abuelos y así
conocer un poco más sobre su vida
en estas entrevistas se hacían preguntas
que podían sacar más sobre el contexto
donde vivieron mis abuelos y qué es lo
que los hizo ser las personas que son
hoy
algunas de estas se realizaban caminando
para simular de la misma manera el mismo
sentimiento que se vivió en esa dichosa
ruta de senderismo
yo al principio no pensaba conseguir
tanto detalle en estas entrevistas pero
me fascinó como de preguntas tan
sencillas como con qué juegas de pequeño
a que jugabas o cómo era una comida
familiar cuando tú eres un niño
llevan a preguntas platicas tan
profundas y tan llenas de historias que
realmente sentías una gran conexión con
él
también este proyecto más que un
proyecto se volvió en en la excusa
perfecta para pasar más tiempo con mi
abuelo y convivir más con él así poder
decir que el día que fallezca yo podría
decir que tengo gratos recuerdos con él
tuve magníficas experiencias y también
que conozco bien a mi abuelo
después tenemos el segundo tipo de viaje
los viajes de aprendizaje
estos viajes se centran mucho en
realizar preguntas a gente de una
localidad sobre las actividades que se
hacen ahí para esto me viene una
historia muy graciosa realmente
que es mi papá y yo fuimos a pescar a
una playa en tampico pero esta vez en
vez de utilizar cañas decimos utilizar
una atarraya
una atarraya para que nos para quienes
no sepan es una red de pesca que se
lanza más o menos de esta manera
habíamos investigado visto vídeos fotos
de todo dijimos ok estamos listos vamos
a intentarlo
fue un desastre no salía se enredaba y
básicamente no salió como lo esperábamos
así que dijimos mira sabes que volvemos
y ahora usamos las cañas
pasa un poco de tiempo y busques
aproximaban a una gente que parecía
experta en la pesca con atarraya ya que
llevan sus propias redes y también
llevan varias varios peces que parecían
recién pescados mi papá me dice
hoy vamos a preguntarles yo creo que
ellos nos pueden decir un poco sobre la
pesca sobre la atarraya tal vez aclarar
nuestras dudas cana teoría yo con la
típica desconfianza y miedo a los
desconocidos dije no porque de dónde
vienen quiénes son los conoces informe
dijo no pero yo creo que los tienen algo
importante que decir y bueno ok nos
acercamos y lo que más me sorprendió era
la amabilidad y el tacto con lo que nos
dijeron las técnicas ya que sin ningún
compromiso ya nos acercamos y es nos
recibieron bien y nos enseñaron aún así
no pescamos nada pero ya no iba a ser
por falta de técnica sino simplemente
por mala suerte lo que les quiero decir
con esto es que no tengan miedo a
preguntar a desconocidos sobre temas o
actividades que les interesen estoy
seguro de que si lo hacen con amabilidad
con ese tacto que quieren los van a
responder de la misma manera también
estoy seguro de que si lo hacen no se
van a arrepentir
después tenemos el tercer tipo de viaje
los viajes de conexión con la naturaleza
estos viajes son de los más sencillos a
realizar pero también con una
importancia muy grande para nuestro
presente
estos se pueden realizar de manera
individual o grupal todo depende de lo
que quieras conseguir en estos
estos viajes se centran mucho en
realizar caminatas en ambientes donde la
naturaleza abunda
por ejemplo para mí estos viajes son
cuando voy a hacer rutas de senderismo
al pueblo donde nació mi abuelo o cuando
hago visitas y caminatas a los parques
en los alrededores de mi ciudad como
chipinque o la huasteca
por ejemplo cuando voy con el papá a
hacer estas caminatas
nos gusta más disfrutar de la belleza
del mundo natural aquí en monterrey por
ejemplo de la belleza árida y urbana de
nuestra ciudad
también nos gusta platicar de temas
variados y así generar momentos de
convivencia tan preciados como son los
de padre e hijo
y también nos gusta recoger basura de
estas áreas verdes dejadas por
visitantes antes que nosotros así
generando un momento de conexión con la
naturaleza mucho más grande
con mis amigos es muy parecido pero más
enfocado hacia la diversión la
convivencia hasta a veces el ejercicio
en fin algo más casual
usted estarán preguntando por qué una
caminata porque como decía aristóteles
caminar nos hace ser mejor humano nos
hace pensar mejor reflexionar mejor y
trabajar mejor
gustaría darles una pequeña reflexión
final
existen muchos tipos de viajes cada uno
con un sinfín de experiencias y con un
propósito distinto
pero lo más importante de estos es el
propósito que les das ya que definen los
recuerdos que vais a tener sobre él y
por qué un viaje sin propósito
no genera grandes recuerdos
también me gustaría decirles que no
necesitas ir al otro lado del mundo ni
gastar mucho dinero para disfrutar de
una auténtica esencia viajera muchas
gracias